uh doc have you ever had a heart attack
yourself
better not no i was going to say no but
the only reason i ask is because for you
to know
so if you've never had a heart attack
yourself
to the average person who you know
because i'm you've written the books you
know new york times bestseller there's a
number of books
you've written on health you know the
planned paradox you're talking about the
energy paradox that's coming out i think
march of 2021
which is very exciting to see that one
coming out but for the average person
that's not in your world that they're
just living their lives they're trying
to pay their bills they're trying to
build their business they're trying to
move up in life and at the same time
enjoy their lives
one how do we go about preventing like
one is preventative what can i do from
the preventative standpoint
two is you know is there ages like i
went to the doctor this week
uh to do my physical and the nurse comes
on she says have you ever done a uh
colonoscopy i said no she says how are
you i said 42.
she said oh you'll do that when you're
hitting 50. oh okay interesting you know
maybe that's something you do in your
50s okay great
what are some is there a preventative
things i need to be worried about in my
20s 30s 40s 50s you know how often i go
see the doctor what are some things i
can do where i don't have to
one day sit there saying why am i having
this elephant on my chest
well there's a there's a number of
things you can do and it's actually
never
too early to start doing it
one thing i've told anyone who will
listen and
you probably have never had it measured
most doctors will measure of fasting
glucose which is a fasting
blood sugar a lot of doctors will
measure what's called
hemoglobin a1c and if you if you watch
commercials
i got my a1c down um
hemoglobin a1c in general looks at an
average for the two months prior to the
blood test
of how much sugar and how much
protein you're handling
and we use hemoglobin a1c to look at
diabetes pre-diabetes
and as i tell anyone who'll listen
telling somebody they're a pre-diabetic
is like telling a woman she's a little
bit pregnant
um there's no difference between
pre-diabetes and diabetes
which leads me into i think if i tell
people if there is
one blood test that and all you get is
one
and it's an eight dollar blood test you
want to get a
fasting insulin level
and if that fasting insulin level
is above nine
i can tell you that lots of
bad things are in store for you
going forward it is so
predictive of developing heart disease
developing diabetes of developing cancer
developing memory loss parkinson's
alzheimer's dementia like i say if
i had one test uh that's what i would
order and
i have a third year um
residents in family medicine rotate
through my
clinic for a month and this is their
third year before they go out into
practice
and not one so far
of these residents have ever heard
of ordering a fasting insulin level and
don't know the significance of that
the other thing if i had two
tests is i would get
a triglyceride
and hdl level
i quite frankly could care less about
total cholesterol
i could care less about ldl the
so-called bad cholesterol
what i want to know is the triglycerides
which are the first form of fat
that you manufacture from sugars and
starches
and i want to know hdl which is the
quote good cholesterol
and one of the best predictors of
never ever ever getting heart disease is
your hdl and triglycerides should
preferably be
equal and if if possible your hdl should
be
higher than triglycerides so those are
a couple of simple tests to hang your
hat on
so okay so i say i go take this fasting
insulin
insulin test okay and it's above nine
and i have bad things in store there's
bad things coming uh
my way many many different things that
you just talked about right
yeah one what can i do to not get to
that point
and then two if i am at that point what
are my next five moves what do i do next
so can i give you my personal example
sure yes
all right so uh let's back up
over 20 years now here i am at the
top of my career in heart surgery
and i meet a guy who i talk about in the
plant paradox by the name of big ed
um from miami who's got inoperable
coronary artery disease
cut to the chase by following a diet
that
looks like mine now and taking a bunch
of supplements from a health food store
the guy drops 45 pounds
and he reverses his inoperable coronary
artery disease
now what was so interesting at that time
at the height of my career
i had a fasting insulin level of 16
which is insulin resistance pre-diabetes
whatever you want
i had a triglyceride level of 166
and my hdl was 32. that doesn't sound
like one to one to me
uh i had i was obese
uh even though i was running 30 miles a
week i was going to the gym one hour a
day i was doing 5k
10ks on the weekends i was what was
called a clydesdale runner
which is a big fat runner and
yet i had high blood pressure i had
pre-diabetes i had such bad arthritis
i had braces on my knees to run and i
had this crazy cholesterol
profile and i had no idea that i was
insulin resistant fast forward three
months
my insulin level drops to three
my triglycerides drop to 30 my hdl goes
to
82. i lose 50 pounds my first year i
drop another 20 pounds and i've
kept it off for 20 years
and so i had
all the markers of man i'm going to have
heart disease like my dad
you know it's genetic yeah i totally
flipped that around by
changing what i ate and so i
devoted my career to teaching
people how to avoid me which is really
dumb as a heart surgeon
talk about a dumb career move
i mean really but i think that's why
people love you though you you are
genuinely loved by people because you're
the doctor you're the father you're the
uncle
any guy would love to have because the
way you talk
you make me want to take your counsel
versus sometimes doctors speak to you
like you're stupid
your approach is so well received by the
audience
well the other thing that i've promised
everyone who
listens to me is that
for instance in my first book which was
published in 2006
uh 2007 sorry dr gundry's diet evolution
i've changed my views
based on my continuing research on my
patients
who allow me to take their blood every
three months and ask them to do
you know here don't eat that food or go
to costco and get that supplement
and so my views have changed my i've
evolved my
you know my teachings and what
frustrates me
is that i have a number of famous
colleagues
who despite 20 years of advancement
in research haven't changed their views
one iota
on you know what we should do
let me give you can i give you an
example from
this morning so there are there's a
famous
well-controlled diet study
on the prevention of heart disease and
it's called
the lion heart diet it's spelled l-y-o-n
it's leon but everybody calls it the
lion heart
diet study and what they did is they
took
people who had a heart attack
and they divided them into two groups
and it was
uh controlled for five years
one group was going to follow the
american heart association
low-fat diet and okay
that's that's the american heart
association low-fat diet
uh the other group had to follow a
mediterranean diet but they had to
supplement their diet with um
a fat called alpha linoleic acid
now alpha linoclinic acid is
present in canola oil not
much but a lot flaxseed oil is loaded
with
that the best source is perilla oil
which is the
favorite oil of korean cooking and a lot
of japanese cooking
anyhow they were supplemented with this
oil
at the end of three years the study was
stopped because the group with the
mediterranean diet
and the alpha linoleic acid had so
much fewer new events fewer heart
attacks that it was unethical
to continue the study it was stopped
and so they
continued the study for five years
because the other
the one group that was having that diet
and the results continued for five years
now so it's been
well shown and that's just one of the
most famous studies
that a mediterranean diet with alpha
linoleic
acid in it beats the american heart
association low-fat diet and when all
this was broken down it turns out that
the only difference that they could find
in
any blood test between the two groups
was the amount
of ala alpha linoleic acid
in the blood of the two groups
and the higher the better the outcome
now what that tells you is um
have yourself some perilla oil every day
and
but so getting back to this
this morning i got an email from a
patient whose
doctor uh really hated the fact that he
was on my program
and that he has a history of heart
disease
and for god's sake man whatever you do
you
have to start the american heart
association diet
right now and it's like
really don't don't you
read the literature do you want to have
a 30
higher rate of heart disease
um yeah that's what this is what we're
up against
yeah i mean look i was talking to you
about my doctor earlier when i said my
dad's doctor dr
munaf shamji i want to give him a shout
out he's a very nice man he's been so
good to my dad
he treats him like his own dad and and
that's what i want when a doctor treats
my dad like his own dad or
his own family you know you get that
good feeling but sometimes you talk to
some doctors not all of them some of
them are going to make you feel like
you have to stick to this guideline or
else you know kind of it's a little bit
too much there but
you